- Hey, a bunch of us are
going for drinks tomorrow,
you should come with.
- I want to, but I have to wash my hair.
- Well, can't you just come after?
- No.
(upbeat rock music)
- Wow, is that coconut?
- Doesn't it take like 40 minutes?
- Edges teeth, edges teeth.
- Hey Patrice, Patrice,
wait up, I texted you
last night, did you get it?
- Has anyone seen Patrice?
- We're gonna be out all night,
so you can just come
whenever you're ready.
- Y'all gonna be out till the next day?
- Oh my God, your arms are so toned.
What do you do?
(bell dings)
- I can make it.
No I can, I'm good.
- What happened to your arm?
- Girl, wash day.
You know.
- Are you sure you just don't wanna come?
- No, I really have to wash my hair.
(upbeat rock music)